I feel like I have to start by asking
are you sure that you're not ariana
grande yeah you're positive yes when did
you first realize that you could sort of
transfer off to be re because this I
mean this is amazing
I like started like doing it like for
fun and then now it's like kind of just
something I do regularly
when you say regularly how many times a
week almost every day ah like ariana
grande Ayanna grande hariyama grande is
aware of you which is amazing she
actually tweeted I want to read it to
you I just wonder why the cat voice /
dialogue I am sure she is the sweetest
sweet sweet heart for real but it's
definitely bizarre scene people blend
the two worlds what do you feel like
when you saw that tweet acknowledging
your tick-tock videos I was so shocked
like that she noticed me she's like
really nice and I kind of thought was
close she noticed me yeah did she slide
into the DMZ yeah what did she say she
said I'm flattered she just wanted to
let me know that I'm beautiful in my own
way I said thank you and thank you for
being so kind to me and she said like
I'm proud of you so that's amazing yeah
did you reach out first or did she
reached out to me when you see a DM from
Ariana I mean where does your mind go I
was just like shocked like like like
she's my idol so I'm kind of like
shaking a little bit yeah did you guys
talk about potentially meeting every one
of these days yeah she said like let me
know if you're ever going to my
sweetheart or like we can grab a hug so
she invited you backstage yeah do you
have plans to go to the tour might all
have tickets but I would like to get
tickets
Ariana if you're watching um okay
I would love some sweetener tickets I
would love to meet you they love that
they call this a catwalk
because my name is cat and look I'm
walking walking on the catwalk how long
does it normally take you from start to
finish to do just the makeup probably
like about an hour and then what about
the hair 10 minutes that's it yeah
what is the secret to getting this
ponytail so perfect a lot of hairspray
yeah how much hairspray is on your hair
right now well I kind of do like my root
it's kind of just like enough oh it's
kind of cuz her ponytail is very like
slicked back is there the hardest part
to doing this the eyeliner the eyeliner
you have to get it exactly right yeah
[Music]
when you shoot these videos do you sort
of plan them out ahead of time yeah I
plan it like a day before how long does
it take you to film them it's usually
like takes me an hour to do each tik-tok
I love Canada really what do you love
about it hey what is this some kind of
quizzes something what's next for you I
would love to get into acting like a
Nickelodeon show kind of like did you
ask Ariana for any advice no no would
you yeah okay I feel like you could
slide in ask for tickets and for some
advice yeah and she would be happy to
help you have any other celebs slid into
your DMS youtubers like who Tana mojo
yeah and then also like one of the
stokes twins what did they say they said
like you look like her like usually like
when people reach out there they started
off with like you look like Ariana well
while we have you here we've actually
pulled a few clips that we would love to
see you try out and dub if you don't
mind are you up for the challenge yeah
okay do you post something on Instagram
and it's like too saturated and you're
like this is a great photo but I have to
get rid of this is everything my whole
vibe like that's a real thing thank you
for giving us a chance to perform for
you I wanna change thank you where have
you been I joined a prison games
[Applause]
[Music]
you owe me that's perfect
[Music]